des habitations éventrées et des débris
qui jonchent les toits le résultat du
dernier missile russe qui s'est abattu
sur le vive près d'une soixantaine de
logements aurait été touchés par cette
frappe sur place le maire constate les
dégâts il s'agit selon lui de la plus
grande attaque contre des
infrastructures résidentielles dans sa
ville depuis le début de la guerre
les secouristes et les services
municipaux travaillent sur place il est
possible qu'il y est encore des gens
sous les décombres certains ont déjà été
déterrés nous organisons toute l'aide
nécessaire pour les habitants
au pied de l'immeuble des dizaines de
voitures carbonisées les vitres des
appartements ont toutes volé en éclat
sous l'impact
éloigné de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres du front ils vivaient sa
région sont régulièrement la cible
d'attaque comme ce quartier résidentiel
où la frappe d'un missile avait aussi
fait plusieurs morts au mois de mars
également présents sur les lieux le
gouverneur régional s'adresse à la
nation et accuse la Russie de cibler
volontairement des civils
comme vous pouvez le voir l'objectif
ultime de la Russie et de détruire la
nation ukrainienne
mais cette guerre continuera jusqu'à ce
que le dernier ukrainien soit debout
nous trions nous vaincrons
sur telegram le président
ukrainien veut le dire qui a lui promis
une réponse tangible à l'ennemi russe